joining us now to get a bit more
reaction to the second ballot results is
the former health secretary matt hancock
uh richard senac as supporter yep what
do you make of today's results well
clearly this is a big vote of confidence
in rishi sunak a clear winner and with
over a hundred colleagues uh backing him
there's a good reason for that because
he's
proved to be the candidate with the
strong clear economic plan to get us
through difficult times and he's also
the candidate who can
most clearly beat kierstama and protect
this country from starmer and nicolas
sturgeon ripping it up in the future so
you know on on the big things that
really matter
rishi is ahead and that's reflected in
the in the results of the poll today you
say he's ahead he clearly is ahead yeah
clearing the hundreds uh
but is he the candidate with momentum it
was penny morden who picked up most
votes today she perhaps surprised people
with her showing of the first ballot
there's been polling suggesting that she
is mars ahead in terms of popularity
with concept of party members is she
perhaps the one who's coming up on the
inside track well there have been polls
of party members saying rishi's ahead
have been polls saying that penny's
ahead and the most recent polling shows
pennies ahead well these polls are
notoriously difficult with
targeting the tory members in terms of
the polling what matters is the debate
that we'll no doubt have over the next
six weeks
with
highly likely that rishi will get
through now
and i
and whether it's
penny or liz or kemi or tom who are left
in the race we'll go out and have that
big debate out in the country and the
candidates will be tested and challenged
and one of the things about rishi is
that he has been tested and challenged
in possibly the most difficult
circumstances that the country has faced
in peacetime history you know i work
with him on that sat next to him through
it and uh he's got the experience so you
know i know that he's got that
he's got that
that time that he's spent
at the forefront right in the heart of
in the heat of this uh these huge
debates so you know whether it's having
the plan or being able to beat pierce
darma i think that she's the lead i mean
you obviously work closely with rishi
cena but other cabinet colleagues have
got a bit of a different view of it i
think jacob small describes him as a
socialist chancellor well he of course
rishi brought in furlough and saved
literally millions of jobs and i think
that's one of the reasons that he is
ahead when it comes to the public and
one of the reasons that he's more
popular than kirstama unlike all the
other cabinets
is because the public do recognize the
extraordinary lengths he went to to
protect people's lives and livelihoods
during the pandemic but of course it's
about plans for the future and rishi's
set out credible economic plan firstly
dealing with inflation
getting growth going which is critical
and then cutting taxes it's a
responsible
credible plan on the economy and i think
that's why the public increasingly uh
warming to british sooner the public but
it's conservative members of me yeah but
there's a long way to go in that debate
it is a long way we're about four days
in so far you know it is a long way uh
to go but if you look at the uganda poll
he basically loses pretty much every
final run-off with his survival steve
baker was there saying that whoever goes
up against rishi soon after the final
two is going to win among conservative
party members
if you don't support rishi you would say
that wouldn't you what matters is the uh
is the debate that we're going to have
no doubt in the country i think it's
highly likely that rishi's name will be
on that ballot paper i certainly hope it
will
[Music]
ballot i don't um there's four others
and you know there's
three horse race really though right
um no there's four others it's a five
horse race now it was six this morning
so you know that's the purpose of this i
don't think you should rule anybody out
um
what is clear is that there's a very
strong vote of confidence in rishi over
100 of my
my colleagues in fact plus me 100 101 in
total colleagues backing rishi and the
reason is because he's got the economic
plan and he's the one that polling
consistently shows compete here stamina
and winning the next election is
incredibly important for my party you
talk a lot about rishi sunex economic
plan yeah are you concerned about the
tax promises that are being thrown
around by some of the other candidates
and how they're going to be funded is
this realistic economics well i think
it's incredibly important that
we put forward as a party a responsible
credible economic plan people look to us
yes of course to get the burden of tax
down but first and foremost to make sure
that the economy is strong and that we
have responsible policy you know that is
the first task of a conservative
government with inflation running at 10
that is
incredibly
important even more important and you
know we haven't had inflation at these
levels uh for
for a generation so we've got to deal
with inflation then we can get to uh
cutting tax i think that's the
responsible and the right approach and
by the way i think it's also the
approach that will appeal to
conservative party members as well as
the general public
to find out matt hancock thank you very
much
on sky news